Well, the the the core argument of the book is
that Silicon Valley should come to the defense of
the nation that made its rise possible. You know,
I came of age during a generation where there was
so much talent, so much funding really flowing
to Silicon Valley. But to build the trivial and
ephemeral, you know, the iPhones that are in all
of our pockets, it's a wondrous invention. It's
changed our lives. You know, we use the apps. Um,
but is that the is that the best we can do? Is
that the crowning achievement of our civilization?
Shouldn't we be directing more energy, more time,
more heart, more money to the things that
really will move the needle? You know, we're
involved with counterterrorism, national security,
medical research, industrial production. You know,
how can we convince people to spend their effort
and resources, scarce as they are, to what really
matters? Um, I would also say I think you know in
some ways we take for granted the relative period
of not peace but geopolitical stability. It's
September 2025 essentially 80 years since the last
time a nuclear weapon was used in war in Japan of
August of 1945. You know, we read the headlines,
we feel the conflict, you know, horrors and
uh and tragedy across the world, but we have
essentially lived through a very remarkable
period of, I would argue, geopolitical stasis,
if not peace, some degree of stalemate. There has
not been a great powers conflict for near nearly
a century. Yes, it feels like we always might be
on the verge of it. But I do think that we in the
United States and more broadly with our allies
including Germany of course and NATO and Europe
um should not take for granted the extent to
which investment in defense, intelligence,
counterterrorism, software, AI for the battlefield
has helped facilitate a remarkable period of
peace. Billions of people and their children and
their grandchildren have now never known a world
war. We should not take that for granted.
We should be humble in our aspirations. But
uh I think we should make sure we're dedicating
our resources where it matters most. How do you
manage the distributional and equitable outcomes
of the technology come back to the center stage?
Right. Um with the people that have the technology
in their hands right now. Absolutely. And and
there are risks. I think we've never denied that
there are risks and excesses uh and and potential
challenges. I do think we need to think about risk
in the context of what we're trying to achieve.
So, you know, in the context of the consumer
internet or the apps again that really have
dominated this first era of innovation, you
know, I'm much less interested in taking on risk,
but when it comes to counterterrorism, and our
company has certainly been involved in preventing
terror attacks, preventing bombs from going off,
uh, you know, my risk appetite increases in the
context of medical research, oncology, you know,
you know, I'm I'm willing to take on much more
uh much more uncertainty in search of
those outcomes. Absolutely. I also think
that although we should be at times skeptical
and cautious in adopting these technologies,
um we need to be more voracious in our appetite in
terms of incorporating the culture that has been
the precursor to the construction of this software
into government. You know, I think about something
like the F-35 joint strike fighter. This is the
premier jet of our time, conceived of in the mid
1990s under President Clinton. A real market
now with the allies in NATO and elsewhere. Um
this and Mark Millie reminded us of this uh you
know this jet will cost essentially$ two trillion
dollars. Uh its end of useful life will be 2088.
You know this is almost a century for one product.
This is completely alien and foreign to us in
the valley. You know that long of an iteration
cycle. Um what are the odds as Mark Millie said?
What are the odds that a man strike fighter is
winning the skies in 2088? I think all of us
in this room know the answer to that question.
Uh so when it comes to you know medical research
or national security or counterterrorism,
local law enforcement, education, public health,
um how can we shorten those iteration cycles from
a century to 50 years to 25 to two years to two
months and and co-opt some of that energy and
dynamism and that the private sector is expert
at certainly and bring that into government.
I think that's the hope because Palanteer is
really at the core of national security topic
and counterterrorism and and is a very data design
company. What would when you look at Europe today
uh what do you think should be our priorities
um to make sure that we infuse this uh spirit of
disruption at a time when we need to be really I
would say meeting with our moment in history in a
way. Absolutely. Spending is part of it. Money is
part of it. There's no doubt about it. You know,
the US has been spending 3 to 5% of its GDP on
national security for decades now. After 1989,
the fall of the Berlin Wall, we all know that
Europe retreated to some degree uh from its
investment in defense. Um but these these uh you
know, maybe 1.5% creeping up um as I think we all
agree that it should. Uh but those small deltas
in uh amounts spent on defense compound over time.
you know, we all know about investing two 3%
these small differences make an absolute have
an absolute impact um over time. So money is
part of it, but I also think to your question
the there's a more sort of cultural uh sort of
inquiry that's necessary as well and it's about
risk and it's about what incentives we set for our
leaders. In the book, you know, we write about a
very senior admiral in the US Navy named Hyman
Rickover. Uh some of you may of course know him.
Um, Jimmy Carter served under him, former US
president. Uh, he was an irassable fellow. Uh,
kind of abusive, I think would be the technical
term by contemporary standards. Made junior
officers stand in a closet, yelled at them,
bered them. I think in a 1984 interview with
Diane Sory or he had kind of some degree of
uh self-awareness. He said that, you know,
I have I have the charisma of a chipmunk. So, he
knew he was a little bit of a pill, right? Um,
and yet he was the father of the nuclear navy by
no uncertain terms. Uh, he helped take Oenheimer's
invention, the nuclear reactor, Oenheimer and
others, um, uh, from the ' 40s and shrunk it
into something smaller, a nuclear reactor that
could fit on a submarine. So now submarines
could not just remain submerged for days but
weeks and months uh and gave the US and its
allies around the world I think uh an a decisive
advantage over the oceans that persist to this day
and yet you know he had enemies I guess you know
hopefully we don't have too enemies everyone has
some probably but uh he definitely had enemies
and and they they saw him in him I think some
degree of vanity and excess certainly and perhaps
pride. So, in the early 1980s, it came out that he
had been accepting gifts from uh General Dynamics,
which was and is or certainly was the premier ship
builder of the time. But the roster of gifts
was sort of odd and eclectic. It was kind of
uh cutlery and dry cleaning for his suits
and a necklace for his wife, right? You know,
um betraying, I think, a significant degree degree
of vanity and and perhaps pride. And he thought he
was above the rules, but this comes out, you know,
front page of the Times, the usual thing. and he's
he's skewered and this is his fall from grace. Um
and and yet is there no place for forgiveness? Is
there no place for tolerance of the you know the
contradictions and of the human psyche of the
human mind? Uh no place to allow our leaders whose
intentions are aligned with our own and intentions
are noble enough for some degree of error. Um and
I think stories like this and we all know many
uh are are vital to understanding what incentives
we are setting for leaders in the in the US we
have plenty of challenges but certainly in
Silicon Valley and at the company I work for
um there is a significant degree of tolerance
for the complexity of the human mind and as
long as you're noble enough and striving in the
right direction and building something of use to
both yourselves certainly but more importantly
the public um a degree of tolerance for error
I think is vital um you know we have this aspect
ation for our public servants to be our priests
but that may be uh counterproductive in certain
context. I hope that is responsible. How do you
assess the the positioning when you say the west
and the values and some and and the alliances?
Who is then the non-west and how do we uh engage
not engage um uh work with them or against them?
what is the safety distance that you see towards
the rest of the world right in a very globalized
world. So well it's exactly the right question and
we're at time so I'll just finish up briefly. Um
you know the engagement is vital but I do think we
had this fantasy that some civilian technologies
would not necessarily have dual uses. I think
that is a fantasy that's being unwound. I think
we should be skeptical to our partners. Always
seek peace, invest for defense for the purpose
of preventing a war, not fighting one. Um but I
do think the US still has a tremendous advantage
and again if you approach it with humility
uh that advantage can and should be retained.